hey everyone
i will be detailing
the psychonautic experience
that i had of my
heroic dose of psilocybin
so this
is the medium post
you can find the link in the bio
yesterday on december 5th
2020 i took 5 grams
of psilocybin at 5 35
pm prior to ingesting
i made the following intentions
awakening baseline
to channeling the highest and light
architectures
i am alone in my room in complete
darkness
laying on the bed
the following is the log of my
psychonautic
experience
this is a nice photo i took with
the silas i've been outside
within minutes i was contemplating our
perfection
how does billion year fungal
intelligence
catalyze this unveiling
6 15 pm
i felt my brain color space and
conceptual schemas
loosening i began feeling a new
emergence
of creatively connecting unique dots
this is best illustrated by the below
brain connections graphic
which michael pollan also used in how
to change your mind
this is a visualization of brain
connections in a person on psilocybin
on the right and someone given a placebo
on the left and i highly
recommend reading michael pollan's how
to change your mind
if you haven't read it before and we
actually
partnered with
psychedelic seminars in order to host
michael pollan on the show and you can
find
that link in the bio below as well
watch that
everything is relative to the observer's
experience
this is why relationships are
fundamental in
mathematics the three space
reality design with time
may be archetypal for conscious agents
to
explore infinity
6 45 p.m
a little over an hour in i felt how the
body
keeps the score and how psilocybin works
to
awaken us to the areas that are tight
that we must heal i was stretching
opening my body up feeling fresh energy
filling tight
voids that were likely brewing
pathologies from my lack of care
i began feeling a sacred pulsating
relationship
with our gut i began feeling a sacred
pulsating relationship with the truth
of non-duality expressing itself
as illusory diversity
let go of concepts and just
feel
and if you haven't i highly recommend
reading the body keeps the score
by vessel bessel van der kolk
701 pm
diversity in oneness is the mathematics
of the infinite
sri aurobindo and the mother mere alfasa
they kept coming up several times
throughout this journey
don't think just feel
giving birth is popping a soul into the
world
what is reality
i ask you
7 06 p.m about 90 minutes in
my obsession for metaphysical truth
kicked in and things became
really interesting you think
you know but you don't
make sense of your reality
try to make sense of your reality
why do you exist
7 16 pm dig
back in your awareness dig back
far enough in your awareness
what's the truth
what are you
7 36 p.m truth
there are so many layers between the one
infinite
creator and these realities an
endless network of relationships
phenomenology
unfolding endlessly profound
insight after profound insight happening
moment to moment
one has to clear their lens of
perception
to see
the childlike laughter of the infinite
sri aurobindo
and the mother mira of fossa
and this is why aldous huxley and
william blake
talked about cleansing and opening those
doors of perception to the true nature
of reality and being
7 46 pm p.m you are
it
see
the unity of all being existence i and
my father
are one john 10 30.
manus molte corona many hands one heart
e pluribus unum out of many
one the motto of the united states
everything else is just a game an
expression
a play we must visually describe
the nature of reality
what is reality what is it
what is reality what is it
leverage indigenous tribal noises of how
language first started
two hours in a new character was birthed
more to come soon on tick tock and
instagram
i'll give you a little taste of it right
now
it's this balance between being
super duper artistic and playful
and childlike yet serious with the
question
that i propose so it goes something like
what use reality
what is it oh what is it
and so you can see that indigenous
tribal noise is
in there kind of like the first
formations of
language as we were making those grunts
and we're making those clicks and those
noises in order to
describe meaning to one another
and so i'll be as this character was
birthed through psilocybin
it was beautiful i practiced this so
many times what
is reality
what is it oh what is it
and so i was doing that and i was
playing and practicing it artistically
and it's going to be birthed more into
the world
soon it was so fun
7 54 p.m it's a supra rational
enigma sri aurobindo and the mother mira
alfasa
my vision here in l.a capture people
recalling what the nature of reality
is especially when we're talking about
the world's
most influential celebrities and people
out here
is that what can be more powerful than
having
people that are like leonardo dicaprio
lady gaga
that unpack what the nature of
consciousness
and being and reality and maximizing
human potential
are what their investigations have been
with the nature of you are it we
are it the kingdom of god
is within you leo tolstoy
and that's going to catalyze the
awakening at unprecedented levels
other people around the world will
investigate their own awareness
and the nature of their reality that way
faster than ever before
melt melt in these realities
are an expression
807 pm
you're an expression of god
everything is subjective as [ __ ] go
in in in inward inward inward
everything else is subjective story
and when i say inward and inward
and inward and if you keep going back
and think about it like getting to the
root
of your awareness the root of your
consciousness
the more that you practice that process
of going to your pure
awareness before any coloration
before any perception before any stimuli
before
any phenomenology just that basic
bear primal root
of awareness and consciousness that is
what we talk about when we talk about
that i
am-ness that being-ness
okay and if you go and you follow
teachers like rupert spyra who teach
advaita vedanta the direct path he will
explain this to you
in greater depth go and subscribe to his
channel you can find that link
in the bio as well he does a great job
at
compressing and distilling these wisdoms
also
again i've been talking about this on
the show go and listen to bentino
massaro and the mirror talks podcast
that link is also
in the bio below he is a fantastic
teacher
for this process as well
take your breath
take your
breath consciously practice with
this with me right now take your breath
and practice feeling feeling
that fresh oxygenation running in
and then that exhalation of the co2
and you can feel that process that
process
and now i want us to practice seeing
this word okay
say the word
truth
truth and can you feel how
truth
how it rolls off of the tip of your
tongue
truth
now say breath breath
breath truth
breath truth
breath practice that because if you do
you'll come up with the profound
realization
that breath is
truth
in that that gnosis that
embodiment of the knowledge of the veda
experientially
that is
enough to transform your life to the
true nature of being
and it's no surprise that truth and
breath
both end with that th
and now i want you to do another
experience with me
take your hands and slowly slide your
hands
like this one on top of the other
like this so you should be slowly going
like this
and as you do that focus on the breath
so watch ready
and as you slide think about that oxygen
coming in watch
and then out
and you see how every moment is like
that breath sliding in
and sliding out and this is why
heraclitus said ponte ray
everything flows right this is why
srirabindo and the mother alfasa this is
why they say that
becoming is the only being
and this is why we have words
from the traditions of
the indus valley like prana which means
life force
reality is this piranha reality is this
life force
i found myself holding mudras
i was holding these
gesticulations in position
and i was channeling prana
it was beautiful what was coming through
it was majestic
and this is also why sri aurobindo and
the mother mir
consciousness force that this
consciousness force is it's the warmth
of the evolution of consciousness it's
the warmth
of the non-duality expressing
itself artistically and that
it is that prana that life force through
the breath
that awakens us to this process
this was a very profound revelation for
me
so self realization
is inward self actualization
is outward that's the enigma
that's the mystery of
our nature our nature
is perfectly
one infinite creator but expressing
itself as this
gorgeous inner
non-dual piece such it ananda existence
consciousness bliss
and exterior artistry it's
in perfect harmonic balance because the
self-actualization
as so much of our mainstream culture
is propagating with all of the self-help
books and
people like tony robbins helping people
actualize their north stars and gifts
into the world
which is fantastic but it's solely
focused on
one exterior artistic part
of the work which is really important
but
it must be balanced with
self-realization which is the interior
part of the work
because i said guru says if you go in
and do the inner
engineering which is what christ
and buddha and lao tza and confucius and
all of these other
major mystical
figures at the edge of what spirituality
has produced
throughout civilization have done
is that they went all the way in and
in doing so they began channeling the
absolute
highest artistic expression outward
and so this is why we have many of our
problems in modernity
is because we are pursuing
north star actualization but without the
morals
the virtues that moral excellence
the ethics the spirituality
that we find from going self-realization
to the true nature of the unity of all
being in existence that one
infinite creator
and this is why this was the next
profound realization
because the nature of our existence is
literally the balance
between melting inward and expressing
outward it's beautiful
such a profound revelation for me
the trick is to capture the profundity
of a heroic dose
without altering it due to camera
involvement
then share it with the world to
normalize all methods of awakening
to enlighten civilization this is going
to be really
important for us to figure out how to do
properly which is capture people
undergoing and theogenic experiences
and again entheogen meaning unleashing
the divine
within unleashing god within
and as we
aim to capture them in the most
sensitive way possible
we'll be able to
hopefully not alter them so they can
remain
extremely sacred divine and profound yet
be able to share them with the world
because
by having my five-hour
experience captured
and sharing that with the world i can
normalize
these types of entheogenic psychonautics
which then normalize people
to explore the true nature of their
their being their reality their
consciousness their awareness
and this is what we will be doing in our
animated series in anthologies
and all content we are going to be
producing in 2021 and beyond
how do you describe life it's
layered
a non-dual supra rational enigma
expressing itself as god
go back and back and back
all that you find is your being
it is perfect
and this is again balanced because you
have
both the one infinite creator's
perfection
and that that non-duality is expressed
as a diversity in oneness and illusory
diversity in oneness
and that that expression
is of course
perfect like we were saying but it also
is very dual
in the sense that you can clearly see
what the
separation is between suffering and
well-being
or heaven and hell
and so so suffering well-being and hell
and heaven
and so we're moving away from
hell and suffering things like violence
and tyranny
and rape and pillaging and
murder and we're moving towards
flourishing and prosperity and abundance
and meeting basic needs of people
worldwide
and so then you can see there's also a
clear you know
uh one of those two is perfect and the
other one is something we're moving away
from which does not appear to be perfect
but it is in perfect
service to the creation
it takes a while to embody that
knowledge
nine o'clock p.m this was another one of
my favorites
describe it try
the nature is both in and out
it is both inward piece and
exterior artistry and that's exactly
what came to me
while with psilocybin
was that in it's just like that it's
like this
inward piece where you go back and back
and back
to the most primal beingness and
awareness
and consciousness and i am-ness
but at the same time it's balanced with
this like artistic
exterior expressions yeah
and it's best resonant through the heart
of children
if you look at adults they are corporate
they have lost for the vast majority
especially in modernity they feel like
cogs in the economic machine
and for the vast majority they've
completely lost
their exterior artistic
bliss whereas children
are truth
they are that exterior artistry
and so we must not quell their
expression
we must enable it to flourish
and we must retain that through
adulthood as pablo picasso said
and that led to this what do you
not even know that you carry with you
and this also sort of you know can be
well expressed through the
through the
iceberg
in
chapter 9 of high level perception which
is a
it's a new graphic
because the truth is what do you not
even know that you carry
with you so you have the vast majority
of people
that are chilling the tip of the iceberg
where they have a relationship their
consciousness
is in relationship with objects the vast
majority of
time as in their consciousness is
focused
on in this case the cell phone
that's the most popular phenomenon that
billions of people around the world
currently
have and are undergoing and then what
happened is when you go a little bit
lower into the depths of reality what
happens is
you have like what the social dilemma
did
which was it awakened people to the
nature of the subject's relationship
with the object and that's why
the arrow itself is highlighted
and then you go one layer deeper and you
begin a process of where the subject
investigates other subjects
and that's when really profound
realizations begin to happen
and that's when you get feelings of true
empathy behind people's shoes you
realize that
the other is actually the self it's like
an
other self
and that's a very profound realization
and then you get to the depths
of the iceberg this is where you're
literally in the depths of the water
pressure where you have the submarine
on the right illustrating this but you
have consciousness and awareness that is
literally investigating its own nature
so what do you not even know that you
carry with you
if you focus all of your consciousness
and attention on the exterior object of
world you don't even know that you
carry around the i am-ness
of your being and when you don't know
that you don't know yourself
and that's why the maxim know yourself
is one of the top delphic maxims and it
was written
on the top of the temple of apollo at
delphi
you have to know yourself
that's a top perennial spiritual wisdom
so do your best to
truly know what you carry with you
and then this one came
it is just perfect there is no lack
when you get to this point
in the investigation of the nature of
our being you
that there is no lack and once you get
to the point of realizing that there is
no lack and it's just
absolute perfect creation
that's when your
entire essence becomes attuned to that
knowledge embodied and
everything you do is gold from there
everything that you touch is gold from
there
everything that you butterfly effect and
it's a constant process of
continuing to become
more blissful and more peaceful
and more love and more compassion
but you realize that everything on a
moment-to-moment basis
is absolutely perfect even giving that
duality we were talking about earlier
with hell and suffering versus heaven
and well-being
even that is perfect that is the way
that the creation
expresses itself
there are lines to not cross in the
layered creation
the ten commandments and noble eightfold
path
are good examples of rules to follow
never disrupt the intimate union of two
souls it's so layered
describe it try
highly recommend trying this with your
friends
and your family do it on a more frequent
basis as i said
and the tedx san francisco talk that i
did
two years ago these questions
we can't let them atrophy we've
atrophied the question what is the
nature of my consciousness we can't
atrophy that muscle we have to work
out this muscle of what is the nature of
my being
describe describe it try
and do it with friends and family more
often
this was funny when this came through
too
it's the same one infinite creator
that will put their hands in their mouth
sitting next to the another
expression where they are
obsessive-compulsive
cleanly in the middle of a pandemic
non-dual creations and so that's
that's pretty funny that you can have
those two poles
of expression right next to one another
this was also super important
and this is where you get into some of
the
i'll read it first then i'll show you
meet the basic
needs so the individual can solo
and this is where you get into some of
the high level perception designs
where we analogize
that high level perception of a tree
and how you need those fundamental
nutrients at the root level in order for
the tree to blossom
fruits and similarly with the high level
perception of a human
you need the basic needs to be met in
order for it to produce its
fully actualized contributory gifts into
the world
and that's where we draw that analogy
and so within this enigma of non-duality
you have the realization
the self-realization of that non-duality
but you also have the exterior artistic
expression of the individual that is
playing a solo
in the symphony the symphony is the
non-duality the non-dual realization
and the artistic expression of the solo
is when the basic needs are met it fully
enables the creative gifts
and you never know which
meeting the basic needs of people
worldwide
will unleash the next most profound
deployments of
civilization-wide code updates
because where is the next satoshi
nakamoto
that was just 12 years ago and it
profoundly changed
our entire social fabric it's
throwing the archaic infrastructure as a
fiat currency
archiving those codes and producing a
world of
a frictionless exchange of value on a
planetary level and there's much more
with smart contracts
and tokenomics and mechanism designs
that are going to be deployed for
inclusive stakeholding in that space so
meeting the basic needs actualizes a lot
of
unique solo gifts that we don't yet know
so it's extremely important to meet
things like the united nations
sustainable development goals
to eradicate poverty to provide people
with
the basic needs of of water
and of clean and affordable energy
and so we'll prioritize doing this in
our architectures and we'll experience a
lot of really beautiful
gifts
so again meet the basic needs so the
individual can solo
this came up just try going in
in what try going in
in what
again so important to do that inner
engineering to prioritize it
9 54 p.m
where are you at where
does it exist and simultaneity is key
is a phrase that sri aurobindo and the
mother emir al-fawsa talk about a lot
because you can both say that
simultaneously
the non-dual truth is that where doesn't
exist and yet in my
individual solo i am currently in los
angeles
so where does exist in that sense and so
ultimately this is the self-realization
understanding of it where where does not
exist and then the self-actualization
understanding of it is i'm currently in
los angeles
and i'm artistically expressing the
nature of being
and godness through this vehicle in los
angeles
and it's a beautiful flower expression
and just like ea says kanye west
revealing the layers to my soul
you have nothing to do but be
the creative expression that you are
show me what it's like to taste the
grape
can you show me what it's like to taste
the grape right now
it's pretty hard even if i started
sitting here
and chewing a grape how would you
understand what it was like to taste the
grape
it's pretty interesting and this is
where i began kind of
understanding that people like robin
williams and jim carrey and sasha
baron cohen and charlie chaplin they're
the reason why
they make such profound impact into
the heart of civilization is because of
their eccentricity
their idiosyncrasies they choose to
express themselves creatively and
uniquely to a degree where they don't
as alan watts says they don't pander to
the art gallery
they just express themselves uniquely
and they do it in a way
where they are leveraging some of those
like
like indigenous tribal noises and
they're also doing uh
they're doing it in a way that's in a
straight flow state
and they're just expressing themselves
and they're trying to shatter
formal systems they're trying to shatter
cultural norms and they're trying to
snap people into
something that's unique and different
than just this
mechanized nine to five in the economic
machinery
and that's why i also realized that
simulation is way too structured right
now
and we need to portal people directly
into awakening consciousness we're going
too much
in the whole chronological format when
we feature our guests of their journey
and of their development of their north
star
and then only at the very end we talk
about consciousness in the nature of
being
whereas what we'll be doing which we did
today on the show and beyond which is
that we're going to begin with the
nature of consciousness and being
and then throughout we're going to end
up circling into
their journey naturally and how they
became interested
in that self-actualized north star but
we want to relate to their
self-realization
experiences and then this came through
which is cool it does a pretty good job
at explaining it
what is reality it is
this breath of air it is the butterfly
it is the car driving by but it is also
the complicated geopolitical
relationship between the united states
and china
and that's when you realize the layers
you realize the layers
to the creation it's as simple as the
breath
all the way to the complicated
geopolitical relationship between the us
and china
balance looney tunes and normal in the
same person
as we're talking about above we've also
mentioned this children are reality
adults are corporate
10 40 pm non-duality misses the last
layered piece
which is the individual flowering
through the non-duality as a unique
expression of it
and you can see that in the background
that we're looking at
right now
it's the background that i've chosen for
the stream which is what
it's the artwork of alex gray
which i'll show you the the large
version of right here
and so alex gray
and allison gray i would say are two of
the most important people
that we should be looking into
as artists that are trying to express
the nature of reality
and that we should be supporting them
they have a great
project that they're currently building
right now a sacred chapel
and we should prioritize building more
of those across the planet
i'll have their links in the bio below
as well but the reason why this is so
resonant especially with that last
segment about the non-duality
and how the individual flowers through
it
you can see that here it's the
individual that flowers through the
non-duality and this is why
the west has prioritized the individual
and it's woke it's it's awakened the
eastern
mystic traditions to the fact that the
point isn't just to melt into non-dual
self-realization
but it's to melt into self-dual
non-realization and
to uniquely express yourself as an
individual artist
playing your own unique solo instrument
melody
in the symphony and that we must meet
the basic needs of people worldwide to
enable their creative
gifts to flourish but also for them to
be able to realize the true nature
of their reality
and again i highly recommend supporting
alexgray.com a-l-e-x-g-r-e-y.com
go and look at his artwork go and listen
to his cosm podcast
find these links in the bible below as
well and then also
this art is so profound and then this is
cosim.orgcosm.org
the chapel of sacred mirrors and so
it's a very profound project we need
more of these
spiritual creative sanctuaries and
monasteries
around the planet we need more of them
and you can contribute and donate and
become a member i did
earlier this year in 2020 when i was
doing high level perception after i
found out about them
support them and make
your own versions of those as well
around the planet
11 p.m fairly close to end of trip
psychonautics are very important
so we're a little over five hours
now into the trip and i'm coming on the
down
and then this comes through which is
probably the most
succinct way that i've ever expressed
the nature of reality in words
which is the enigma is to realize
non-duality and play your solo
in it from what i understand
that's the enigma the nature of our
being
is to realize that you are the one
infinite creator the non-dual
and also play your unique artistic
solo in it achieve a transcendent
noble aim north star that provides
contributory gifts to
yourself your family the community and
the world
unpacking some synergy i published high
level perception
five weeks ago and took my five gram
heroic dose on december 5th
2020 and started at 5 35
p.m it's pretty gorgeous
and i learned that five in numerology is
about change which is very interesting
no music the whole time a couple
drawings
mostly notes on phone and some voice
recordings
again i was in darkness and
laying in bed alone
and it was very important to me because
it was
that terence mckenna has been a profound
influence on me and so many people
worldwide his novelty theory is very
good
and so is his adamant persistent
philosophy around people undergoing the
heroic dose and what it can do to
actualize the fullest potential of our
planet
and so you'll hear me talk about the
ways that we are currently
making and the agendas more
mainstream here in a moment
42 p.m six plus hours in
celebrating with a hot shower cleanse
and with grapes and food i'm 24 plus
hours fasted
i'm grateful for all of this
infrastructure and i'm pumped to post
all this tomorrow
all right so now the why
why i publish this all right
so now we're going to talk about
mainstreaming and theogens
first of all i'm a big proponent of maps
the multidisciplinary association for
psychedelic studies
find their link in the bio below we've
interviewed their founder and executive
director
rick doblin several times on the show
and you can find this interview link in
the bio below
as well it's a very very important
episode
and here's the maps.org website
as well multi-disciplinary association
for psychedelic studies be the bridge
support the psychedelic research
and education and donate to them you can
listen to rick's
profound ted talk on the future of
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy
you can listen to ceo amy emerson
speak
you can look at all of the profound
press releases that they're having right
now
and so here's kind of what's going on
i need to share information about them
because they are carrying the biggest
entheogenic torch enlightening our
future that we all need to respect and
support
more both financially and in spirit
maps was awarded breakthrough therapy
designation by the fda for helping
veterans and other first responders with
mdma psychotherapy to cure ptsd
eliminating suicidal inclinations and
helping them process
and integrate fearful memories in
peaceful ways
cannabis psilocybin lsd ketamine
ayahuasca ibogaine and more are also
being used by maps and their affiliates
in psychotherapy sessions across the
world
to cure everything from drug addictions
eating disorders and ocd
all the way to couples therapy and
having a peaceful
end of life we must become
advocates for transitioning from a
criminal justice approach
to a public health approach in
worldwide transgenerational healing
and awakening to the true nature of our
being we must
leverage the fullest potential of
entheogens across the planet
to heal and to awaken us to the true
nature of our being
and thank goodness we have maps carrying
the brightest torch
moving forward and we must also
decentralize
entheogens as well and not allow the
the similar style infrastructures to
emerge where there's the corporatization
of entheogens we must decentralize these
are literally psilocybin
and mycelium fungi are decentralized
underground which you'll see here in a
moment that i explain
so here's a photo of me
with my heroic dose this is when i was
doing my
intention before
i started
okay second of all i was called
intuitively to another and theogenic
experience after several
years without one and i have spent the
last couple of years about over
over half a decade about over half a
decade i've been
experiencing 5 m eodmt
lsd and
cannabis and i've been dabbling into
anthogens and there are still many that
i will be undergoing
but that these have been some of the
most profound experiences of my life
and i took a decently long enough break
so that i could focus on
the the execution of
the show and high level perception which
had went great
but i wanted to undergo this anthogenic
experience on the heroic dose of silas
i've been before the final publication
of eye level perception
this week it's important for me after
such a long 2020 of synthesizing the
most profound things i've learned
about the nature of consciousness
reality and maximizing human potential
to anchor my embodied learnings by
loosening the default mode network
dmn and ensuring my final publication is
in the top
perfection possible i learned for the
most part it is absolutely perfect
i've been adamant about biomimicking the
intelligence of mycorrhizal networks
which create an
underground two-way resource exchange
with 95 percent of plants
and you have to watch this link in the
bio as well this is suzanne simmers ted
talk on how trees talk to each other
and how they use these mycorrhizal
networks in order to do so
and this is what you literally feel you
feel this intelligence
pulsating through your entire body when
you ingest
psilocybin it's profound you literally
feel this intelligence throughout your
whole body
and so i unpack this in more detail here
chapter five and high level perception
on inclusive stakeholding
is not a recommendation it's an embedded
biological archetype
which is why the internet and
decentralization technology have emerged
the last couple of decades
everyone deserves skin in the game with
a piece of equity in the history of our
species
and if you haven't read that book skin
in the game by nassim nicholas taleb i
highly recommend
reading that book as well as we leverage
mechanism design in our social contracts
that biomimic fungal intelligence we
meet the basic needs of people worldwide
and maximize their self-realization
and self-actualization
so now you see that this the idea
of these emerging markets whether it's
entheogens or
cannabis and hemp or blockchains and
cryptocurrencies
that as these emerging markets explode
the edge of
knowledge and what civilization knows
and there's more entrepreneurship and
there's more creativity that emerges and
there's more
of the pie grows it's important that as
the pie grows especially in the
entheogens field in the decentralization
field
that we don't create
the similar archaic processes that have
existed in the past where
people become exclusively stakeholder
where
only the top elite take the vast
majority of the wealth of the emerging
market
and leave just scraps
for other people we must inclusively
stakehold everybody
and give everybody a
a fair share in the emerging market
we are publishing high-level perception
through book writing hub an independent
book publisher outside the
archaic incumbent infrastructure that is
more inclusive modern and respectful of
their artists
it will be available for hard slash soft
cover and digital slash audio across all
major retailer slash platforms before
christmas
it's a perfect gift for awakening and
you support all my major long-term goals
by contributing
it comes from a deeply scientific and
spiritual angle using explain like i'm 5
eli 5 visuals to make it more relatable
especially for
kids and the whole family it's a great
book to have in your home and share as a
gift to your closest friends
the links in the bio to that and
i especially want to thank the healing
hustlers
sky and sunny i love you both so much
thank you and watch our episodes with
them here
this is the one with skyra on a slice of
life force
and this is the one with sunny on magic
mushrooms the links are in the bio to
these as well
i'm very pumped to be co-creating with
them
the future and lastly i want to thank my
mom
bella for the foundation she laid in my
soul
to enable me to achieve my goals my
mamachika
i love you i hope you can open up and
accept this post for what it means to me
and the world i adore you
and godspeed team we got this
atlas this is a nice picture of my mom
and i
from the summer of 2020 when i was at
home publishing
high level perception
i love my mom so much dedicated so much
of her life to
building the foundation for me to
achieve everything that i am today
i adore you mom i love you mama
i love you and then this is some very
beautiful artwork
at the very end of this post
and this is the artwork that's by it's
called spiral speak by sam brown and you
can find
the link to his site here as well
and i end with diversity in oneness
is the mathematics of the infinite sri
aurobindo and the mother
meera alfasa and
i literally spent months
reading their work over the summer of
2020
and i published this synthesis
video distilling their most profound
teachings
and it's only 40 minutes long you can
find that link in the below as well
and that you can
for the most part you can almost
shortcut the months of reading by
watching this
several times slowly taking notes
and practicing embodying their teachings
and that's it that's that's that's all
it's all folks that's
my heroic dose of psilocybin
you can find this medium post the link
in the bio share it with other people
also share this video with other people
we definitely need to popularize and
mainstream
people becoming more open to anthogens
and what they unlock for understanding
the true nature of our being
both on a self-realization level and a
self-actualization
level and let me know your thoughts in
the comments below
on what i shared with you i'd love to
hear from you like the video subscribe
and some of the other
super interesting oh just briefly all
i'll share with you guys if you follow
the healing hustlers
on instagram go and give them a follow
links in the buy below to that as well
and then what i'll do
is i'll just very briefly also
i'll share with you the
i had i had listened to
kilindy who had recently passed
speak about his 40 years
of experience with entheogens
and how he's taking high doses of
psilocybin 20 to 30 grams
at a time uh he was also saying that
you you the lethal dose of psilocybin
is literally taking your body weight in
psilocybin so you're not going to take
150 pounds of
psilocybin so you can take like a pound
of sila sibin
if you would like it's crazy and so he's
doing this in order to push the envelope
of cognition
to access the hyperdimensional realms of
legend
and instead of just putting your foot in
the water of existence to go into the
ocean
where there is no horizon
he spoke about how the zulu in south
africa has
300 types of entheogenic plants in their
pharmacopoeia
you got to think about that you have
there's these indigenous people like the
zulu compared to look at this industrial
modern machinery that has zero enviogens
available
they basically just have cannabis
available it's horrible
silas ibn is the oldest and the first of
the antiogens
saturates the serotonergic system
the other interesting thing is that
ayahuasca is like a group experience but
psilocybin is the journey of the alone
into the alone
it's pretty interesting you have to meet
the center of being by yourself you have
to meet the center of reality
by yourself you understand the nature of
your being
and your awareness and your
consciousness in your reality
by yourself you meet it you know it on
an experiential level
and mushrooms
they're all over thousands
of years of culture across the planet
thousands of years of culture artistic
expression
from north africa through the ancient
egyptians through
mesopotamia in this valley through south
america through native america and north
america as well
through the through the asian continent
as well it's all over the place all
over the place and so we have to become
more aware
to our divine
history with entheogens especially
with psilocybin magic mushrooms
and i'll go ahead and link
the kill in the e talk in the bio below
as well for you and so again
go and support go and support maps
go and support the other
people around you that are pushing the
envelope especially of entheogenic
experiences
to decentralize those around the world
and also to
awaken us to the true self-realization
of the nature of our being and the true
self-actualization
of our gifts into the world at the
highest level of morality ethics and
spirituality
so i love you very much thank you for
tuning in i'm really grateful for you
thank you thank you thank you
we got this we got this so pumped
so pumped so beautiful
all right much love thanks for tuning in
talk to you more soon check out all
those links in the bio below
let's build the more beautiful future
our hearts know is possible
charles eisenstein